[Inaudible] [inaudible].
I also [inaudible].
Yeah.
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible].
Oh yeah.
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] good. [inaudible].
[Inaudible] Oh yeah.
[Inaudible].
Um, not cause she's good at both.
Yeah. [inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible].
Yeah.
[Inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] uh [inaudible]
uh, well Dov or do, uh, uh
[inaudible] uh, or so harder. E
[inaudible], uh, or I'll do Blair. Uh
[inaudible] uh
[inaudible] [inaudible].
[Inaudible] um, so
[inaudible] so
[inaudible] the work is acute nursing and moved to my so egg.
Uh.
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] OLED. Um,
I cannot directly make the move to Los. I cannot do some bread.
[inaudible] martyr [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] so I wanted to [inaudible] men and Finca
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible] and I'll do my
Yeah.
[inaudible] of
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] through this, on the Kubota mags.
[inaudible] the
[inaudible] [inaudible] manager on
[inaudible] for [inaudible]. Oh. The scarier,
but Minda of whole summons, some sticker porcelain.
[Inaudible] um, yeah.
[inaudible] yeah. [inaudible].
Oh yeah. And I have [inaudible] and
[inaudible] um, man, that's some shut the vial down. Uh
[inaudible] [inaudible] so I will listen. Okay. The literally
[inaudible] some [inaudible] so I will let slide
collabora
[inaudible] can find him except for him to try or Sitka ferning
underlay talk a little sweet Churchill. Los Angeles.
[inaudible].
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] uh [inaudible] uh
[inaudible] [inaudible].
[Inaudible].
Nah, I saw, uh, [inaudible] Los Angeles
[inaudible] so I forgot. [inaudible] so,
so, so
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] uh,
the town for rehab for my
[inaudible] or
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible].
We'll take it order.
[Inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] or
[inaudible].
Yeah, you
[inaudible] to [inaudible] the moment you bought a large site
[inaudible] and stop Mount SATA. Um, and man, I,
I, and again,
[inaudible] fail at the, bless us in the black
[inaudible] now. Uh, um, [inaudible] so,
um, for Mr. [inaudible], Mr. Shan,
also it's an episode, uh,
they should have fled a gun in New York or on the classical reality.
So my editor for management and
[inaudible] external
[inaudible] uh [inaudible] so
[inaudible] [inaudible] and maggots [inaudible].
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible] uh
[inaudible] [inaudible].
[Inaudible] and can we, uh, yeah, uh
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] mm [inaudible].
Hourly Lauren
[inaudible] medicine, special comma model. [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] as a me gag, Krista
[inaudible] health, for example, [inaudible] three,
whole months to croquette you onset
[inaudible].
Okay, good for now.
Absolutely. Yeah, I was
[inaudible] my name was [inaudible].
We'll do it all. If I can get some songs that, uh,
plot the [inaudible].
I mean, examp do
[inaudible] or ag
[inaudible] drink and do some good fresh [inaudible] excellent. So
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] the culture culture. The other culture we can hop on a plus
[inaudible] [inaudible] exempt.
[Inaudible].
I have
[inaudible] LA live constantly as a film TV.
[inaudible] it's what is this?
[inaudible] [inaudible] somehow even how you can at
[inaudible] as a [inaudible] function,
the name indicates pertain insofar as they're below a year, they
[inaudible] stop [inaudible].
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] in store,
but they have a coup they have a cooker eat and Sasha is the mucus Puffin
Madigan can't communicate Kate Muscatine.
Therefore I am an inter sear mentor. Legally,
you could pull events as a team daily to Nemo as if say,
Sinan say this where I see before coming from Tacoma, for example,
in downtown Drager, I mean, you have [inaudible] Lao,
comma Heaton, and score this for you to go. It can't delete the photo.
You can delete the Potter. Oh yeah. [inaudible] yes.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
dial-in um, dial-in so I'm just
[inaudible] [inaudible].
[Inaudible] I'm from
[inaudible] if the chameleon raccoon is
[inaudible].
[Inaudible].
That's a deer
[inaudible] [inaudible] thing. [inaudible] put
[inaudible] share
[inaudible] [inaudible] blah-blah-blah eh, or is it
[inaudible]?
Yeah, I think
[inaudible] add as a [inaudible] of
[inaudible] could have drive experiment tech, uh, uh,
[inaudible] uh, um, verbally creative example. Uh
[inaudible] and that's what should the Sandra I was at
[inaudible] minister shut the salmon of athletes,
some juice and took all of that or you and my handicap, her, uh,
Wolf of wall street, Mellon
[inaudible] [inaudible] some bio ag. And I ask you for a log in law, Mr.
Tank get there.
[inaudible] so definitely kicker
[inaudible] sound on a dense nodes. I moved my
[inaudible]. They have the listening for Tina
[inaudible] inside job. Do do.
Do I, Oh, uh, a dog
[inaudible].
Adam
[Inaudible] familiar.
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] did I lose [inaudible] and
I'll say [inaudible], let's go be
[inaudible] night. Yeah.
[inaudible]
It books in a folk song.
[inaudible].
[Inaudible]
uh, uh, spirituals also do, uh,
American spiritual. Yeah. Um, [inaudible]
vitamin [inaudible].
And I, I guess on pump tests that's really
[inaudible] yeah.
[inaudible] [inaudible] it a health spread
[inaudible] spirituals.
[inaudible] the [inaudible] or the
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] so
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] Fermin Fetzer.
[Inaudible] uh, [inaudible].
I'm going to tell God all of my troubles.
Holly. Sorry about to move for lovely to
[inaudible].
[Inaudible]
trouble's
gonna tell him the road was Rocky when
I get
[inaudible] [inaudible].
Spilled a little further in a baby.
[inaudible] so then I, again
[inaudible] is though, sorry, again.
[inaudible] I've been NuRelic some divine thing around a Helton
has
[inaudible] [inaudible] yeah.
[inaudible].